hey luke here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we are talking about
tinder no we're not swiping left or
right we're lighting stuff on fire now
we've done a lot of fire tutorial videos
i've shown you guys how to build fires
in the pouring rain i've showed you guys
the best ways to start fires without
using matches so today we're going to
talk about picking the right tinder well
there's a lot of different ways to start
a fire and depending on which tools
you're using depends on which tinder is
right for you whether you're using flint
and steel ferrous rods matches or a
lighter so i've tried to gather up every
conceivable fire starter known to man
whether it's commercial store-bought
man-made or all-natural
and we're going to experiment with all
of them and see which works best for all
the different fire starting techniques
and we're going to go quick because we
got a lot to cover the first thing we're
going to review is char cloth it's just
charred cloth it's used to catch sparks
and turn them into embers you put it
inside your tinder you blow boom fire
you can't ignite most tinders with flint
and steel so you need the char cloth to
catch that spark and turn it into an
ember so then you can make fire char
cloth has been around for hundreds of
years and it can be made from canvas
linen or any cotton material and the
weird thing is you can't light it on
fire char cloth only makes embers you
can make your own char cloth with rags
from a linen shirt put it in a metal tin
heat it up over towards your fire until
flames start coming out the sides then
blow those out let it smolder for a few
minutes and the really black charred
cloth will work great for catching an
ember don't use the brown stuff it will
not catch an ember but those same linen
rags make an excellent tinder they'll
actually burn and they're very windproof
ferrous rods don't work well with normal
linen rags unless you shred them up
first then they work great as a tinder
and a fire starter
if you have a knife and some wood you
can make wood shavings one of my
favorite fire starters it lights easy it
burns hot and burns a pretty long time
it can't get ignited with just a flint
and steel unless you have char cloth but
with a little work you can ignite dry
shavings with a ferrous rod let me give
you a quick tip about using a ferrous
rod pull the ferrous rod towards
yourself don't flick the steel towards
the tinder doing this busts your
knuckles and it knocks your tinder all
over the place it puts out your flame
okay let's talk cattail fluff it ignites
extremely easy but it doesn't burn very
long doesn't burn very hot it's great
for using a ferrous rod but you've got
to add something to it to get it to
really catch fire i like to add grass or
dry wood shavings and then it works
pretty darn well i've tried a million
times to try to light it with flint and
steel but it just doesn't work i get
almost exactly the same results from
cottonwood fluff and thistle down it
ignites really easy but doesn't burn
very hot or long okay this is the
shredded bark from an aromatic cedar
tree and it's one of my favorite fire
starters cedar bark lights easily it
burns reasonably hot and long and it can
be found almost all over the country
cedar bark is a great tinder if you're
using a ferrous rod and if you're going
to be using flint and steel of course
you're gonna have to use char cloth to
light it but cedar bark is great for
turning an ember into a flame pine pitch
or pine tar it's mother nature's napalm
but unfortunately you've gotta melt it
before it'll catch on fire once you do
it burns hot and it burns long it works
best mixed with other things fatwood is
pine wood saturated with pine tar you
get it from the base of standing dead
pine trees it has a strong pine smell
and when you make little shavings out of
it you can light it with a ferrous rod
when you heat up fat with the pine tar
oozes out and catches on fire fatwood is
a great tinder for lighting wet wood on
fire you can often find pine cones with
white bits of pine tar stuck in them and
these will work a lot like fat wood they
burn hot and they burn long this is a
quick and easy fire tinder that's great
on rainy days
dry dead pine needles are not a bad fire
starter i like to rough them up a little
bit make sure there's a lot of air
inside and then they burn reasonably
well and they get a good flame and you
can actually start a decent fire with
them pine needles don't work well with a
ferrous rod but if you've got an ember
you can light them up pretty good
birch bark is a classic fire starter
there's lots of different types of
birches and lots of different types of
bark but they all burn reasonably well
they burn hot and they burn long if you
use the outer bark which is kind of
paper-like or really fine shavings you
can align them with a ferrous rod and it
makes a really good flame
spanish moss is a really fun fire
starter but you got to use the dead
stuff on the left the stuff on the right
is alive and green and will not burn
the dry stuff burns like gasoline it is
crazy how hot and fast it burns the
green stuff doesn't work at all and it
doesn't work with a ferrous rod tinder
fungus or chaga grows on the side of
trees and deciduous forests and it's a
real specialty tinder it doesn't burn
but it makes incredible long-lasting
embers and chaga is great for saving and
transporting those embers so you can
make fire later just take a cola and
ember and put it on a piece of chaga and
occasionally blow on it and it'll glow
for days you know chaga just smolders
really slowly so you can transport this
and carry it through the woods you can
also make your fire put an ember inside
the chaga go to bed at night and then
when you need to start your fire in the
morning you've got an ember still
burning in the chaga having a little
smoldering chaga around you also can
give you a little bit of relief from the
mosquitoes but not not much
coconut fibers are a great fire tinder
you can ignite them with a match or with
a ferrous rod and they burn really hot
and long
coconut fibers also take an ember really
well so it's great for friction fire
methods or using flint and steel
if you got a match or lighter palm
fronds work really great for lighting
fires they're a great tropical tinder
that burns hot and long
but normal leaves are not a great tinder
a lot of people try to use them and they
start to light and then they smolder
leaves work a little better if you
crinkle them up first but still they
have a tendency of lighting for a few
seconds and then just going out and
smoldering occasionally you can get a
good fire off them but they're one of my
least favorite fingers lighting dead
leaves with a ferrous rod is extremely
difficult picking up fine tiny dead
sticks off the ground is a much better
tinder than leaves it lights reasonably
well with a match or a lighter and it
burns hot and long and it's the way i
start most of my fires
bird feathers do technically work as a
fire starter but they tend to melt
rather than giving off a good flame and
they're really susceptible to going out
with even the slightest breeze they also
don't work with ferrous rods
human hair for my wife's brush works a
lot better it lights pretty easy and it
produces more of a consistent flame you
can even light it with a ferrous rod but
the type of hair you use makes a big
difference i experimented with a lots of
different types of hair beaver hair
doesn't work very well at all
i can try even lining it with a match
and it didn't work well sheep's hair was
okay got the best results
but still not great and rabbit hair
didn't work at all
all right let's talk to her dried cow
poo it is a great fire starter it
behaves a lot like charcoal it's a
little hard to get started but once you
blow on it a ton it makes excellent
coals that are great for cooking over
one of my favorite natural fire starters
is oakum and it comes from jute or hemp
rope and you just unravel it and make
this little rat's nest and it lights so
easily even with ferrous rods it lights
so easily you just unravel the rope and
kind of mess it up and get it as scruffy
and rat nest like as you can and it
catches a spark extremely well it burns
long and it burns hot
if you want to put it on a belt sander
you can make super fine okum that lights
really well if you have an ember you can
put that in the oakum it lights up
really well burlap is just made from
jute or hemp and so you can rough it up
and turn it into oakum and it burns
really well
toilet paper it's the fire starter of
boy scouts everywhere it lights
extremely easy it doesn't burn for very
long and the wind likes to blow it away
but you put a little rock on it and you
can even light it with a ferrous rod all
paper products work pretty good as fire
starters however if you use too much of
it it can produce a lot of ash that can
smother the fire
if you rub the newspaper back and forth
it will get soft like toilet paper and
then you have a good chance of being
able to light it with a ferrous rod
the same thing applies to paper towels
they light really well with matches and
liners and if you want to use a ferrous
rod scuff it up really well shred it up
and then it'll take a spark piece
same thing applies with fast food
napkins scuff them up shred them up then
you can catch a spark on them it takes
some work but it does work
you can get the same results with all
different type of paper products the
thicker the paper is the more you have
to rough it up and shred it up but you
can get it ignited with a spark even
cardboard will work if you shred it up
and rough it up enough
one of the best tinders to use is pet
cage liner made from recycled paper you
can buy it at pet stores or walmart and
it burns for a really long time burns
reasonably hot and it takes a spark
really well you can make something
similar to this by shredding up a
cardboard egg carton
dried grass works really well as a
tinder especially if it's bone dry and
it's very fine you can light it with a
match you can line it with a lighter you
can even start it with a ferrous rod and
you'll get a pretty decent flame
coarser grasses like this wheat here
much harder to light on fire ferris rods
don't work but matches and lighters work
reasonably well
it burns long it burns pretty hot it
makes an okay fire starter
one of my favorite tinders is cotton
balls they're so easy to light
especially when you're using a ferrous
rod it just takes one strike and that's
it but they don't burn all that long so
we add a little bit of petroleum jelly
to them and they light just as easily
but burn much longer much hotter now the
weird part about this is that petroleum
jelly doesn't burn well by itself you
try to light it with a match or a
lighter and nothing really happens you
have to add some sort of combustible
material to it to get it to do anything
while i like to use cotton balls any
type of cotton product works really well
these cotton rounds were great
especially if you tear them apart a
little bit
q-tips work good especially if you kind
of unwind them a bit anything that you
can find that's made out of pure cotton
is going to work really well to light on
fire and if you add a little bit of
petroleum jelly to it it's going to burn
even better
even dryer lint is mostly made out of
cotton and it burns reasonably well not
quite as well as pure cotton cotton
balls but it'll take a ferrous rod just
fine
steel wool is one of the more unique
fire starters we're going to discuss
it's like char cloth on steroids the
smallest spark and it turns into this
massing glowing ember and if you blow on
it it gets crazy huge and hot very
quickly
it'll never produce a flame even if you
expose it to a lighter or a match or
throw it in a fire it'll just make an
ember but this ember can be used to make
great fires by mixing it with some sort
of combustible material like wood
shavings for instance small spark and
boom you have a great hot fire you can
even make fire with a dead lighter that
doesn't have any gas in it
and it works with flint and steel it's
one of the only other tinders that'll
actually make an ember with flint and
steel steel wool is an extremely
effective char cloth substitute
magnesium is another strange fire
starter that they sell at the camping
stores you make these little shavings
off the back side and you flick it with
a ferrous rod and you get a decent
little flame that burns really hot if
making your own magnesium shavings is
too much work you can buy your own and
they produce a lot of heat a lot of
light it's particularly effective when
you're dealing with wet wood match light
charcoal briquettes can work pretty well
as a fire starter one single briquette
doesn't work very well at all but if you
add a pile of them then they light quite
easily with a match breaking up one
briquette into a lot of little chunks
also works pretty well charcoal
briquettes burn hot they burn long but
they don't work well with ferrous rods
the charcoal left over from a fire can
be used as a fire starter but you really
need a lighter to do this you light one
corner of it get a little amber going
and keep blowing until that amber grows
and grows until it becomes a flame if
you wake up in the morning and want to
restart your fire this is a great
technique for doing that i've tried many
times to start charcoal using just
matches but it's pretty hard to do
all right tumbleweeds they're long
pieces of wood shaving soaked in
paraffin wax
if you unravel them you might be able to
start it with a ferrous rod i've done it
before but i couldn't do it for this
video lights super easy with matches or
a lighter burns long burns hot it's a
great and easy way to start a fire
black beard they advertise a lot online
it's basically rope soaked in some sort
of oil not that easy to start actually
even with a match but once it gets going
it burns really hot and for a very long
time it's like an oil well fire but you
can't use a ferrous rod with it so that
doesn't work
you can dunk it in water and then light
it with a match so that's kind of cool
um but
that's about it not one of my favorite
fire starters
this stuff um is okay i mean it's kind
of gooey it won't start with a ferrous
rod lights okay with a match it's you
know burns a long time you're supposed
to go and light the wrapper and then
just build a fire over the top of it and
you know works okay
um this is my favorite fire starter the
zips uh you can light the wrapper and it
just goes and burns for a long time very
hot it's also very light it's made out
of like styrofoam and oil but this stuff
does not go out i mean it doesn't matter
if it's pouring rain blowing wind or
what you light that on fire that is not
blowing out at all
um it just burns
look at that
i mean you could light that in a
hurricane
and it ain't going out
you can pour water on it
it ain't extinguishing
it's pretty amazing stuff it lights
super easy with a ferrous rod i couldn't
get it to light with just flint and
steel but you can dunk it in water and
you can see how light it is it so it
doesn't take up a lot of weight in your
backpack but even soaked in water it'll
light
especially if you crumble it up
but uh even after it was soaked in water
i could light it with the ferrous rod
this stuff
is basically cardboard soaked in
paraffin or some sort of oil
it worked okay
you know but after that other stuff that
zips i wasn't that impressed it wouldn't
light after it got wet unless you tore
it up into shreds you could get it to
light with the ferrous rod if you
shredded it up a little bit but you know
you can do that with normal cardboard
too
this is another zips product but a
little bit more for fireplaces and less
for camping
if you shred it up you can get it to
light with a ferrous rod but it's
difficult
it's
lights really easy with a match burns
long burns hot like all of these
products do but honestly none of these
were as cool as those little gray
styrofoam bricks that zips make
this is the zippo's lighting paracord
which i did not like it's stiffer
heavier and more expensive than normal
paracord you pull it out and there's
this one little waxy red thread you can
light it on fire and it makes
about as much flame as a birthday candle
it's really not impressive you compare
that to normal paracord and it's even
less impressive
so here we go this is a piece of normal
paracord here i'm pulling out the nylon
inside and opening it up and when you
compare the two i just don't see the
advantage of using the zippo fire
paracord
this is another fire tinder i didn't
like it looks like a little cotton round
soaked in paraffin really hard to light
on fire and the shape is weird you got a
little better results if you tore it up
first but it blows out really easy it
doesn't produce a particularly big flame
if you dunk it in water it won't light
so i really just didn't see the point
but i did like the tin and it's great
for making turquoise
let's talk paraffin wax you can buy it
in blocks or in candles it's a great
ingredient in homemade fire starters but
it doesn't burn itself you have to add
it to combustible materials and then
it'll make that material burn longer and
brighter just like this paper towel here
you've got the one on the right is
soaked in paraffin the one on the left
is not and you can see it's also very
wind resistant paraffin itself doesn't
burn the fumes it gives off when you
heat and melt it that's what catches on
fire when you extinguish this candle and
put a match near it you can see the
fumes above the candle light on fire but
a little candle like this under a pile
of sticks is a great way to start a fire
rubbing alcohol or isopropyl alcohol or
denatured alcohol will burn very easily
but it doesn't produce a very hot flame
or a very long lasting flame
you can light it with a ferrous rod
which is very convenient but you can't
light it with flint and steel you can
light it with an ember anything that
contains rubbing alcohol like hand
sanitizer can also make a flame but the
flame is often invisible and hard to see
which makes it a little bit dangerous
you can even light it when it's on top
of water which is kind of cool when
everything's wet
pretty much any aerosol contains alcohol
including bug repellent and sunscreen
but the flame goes out really quick
because it's not pure alcohol so it's
not a very good fire starter and once
the flame goes out there's a bunch of
leftover liquid that acts as a flame
retardant which makes it harder for the
wood to catch on fire if you're going to
use aerosol spray cans as a fire starter
you've got to act quickly before all the
alcohol evaporates out of it
and you need some sort of secondary
tinder to take advantage of that flame
you can ignite aerosols with a ferrous
rod
lamp oil behaves a lot like liquid
paraffin it doesn't light very easily on
its own you expose it to an open flame
and not much happens honestly but if you
combine it with other sort of
combustible materials like a cotton swab
or some sort of wicking substance then
it burns really well and long and it
produces a decent flame it's not a
particularly hot flame but it's a lot
more stable and less dangerous than
other petroleum fuels
lighter fluid is only slightly more
volatile than lamp oil you put a flame
on it and not much happens right away
until it gets heated up or you've put it
over some sort of combustible material
if you put lighter fluid on a piece of
towel for instance then it burns really
well just like lamp oil you can actually
make a little stove using a wick and a
little bit of lighter fluid and a tint
can and it works really well for warming
your hands or heating up some water but
be careful these petroleum products get
more dangerous as they get heated up and
they become extremely volatile when warm
the most dangerous fuel is white gas or
gasoline it is extremely volatile and
likes to blow up in your face you can
light gasoline with a ferrous rod but
you have to be careful the invisible
fumes from the gasoline likes to creep
out sideways and blow up in your face
you can reduce this by putting the
gasoline in a can and this reduces the
oxygen and contains the fumes but be
careful because if that can tips over
flaming gasoline will spray everywhere
and get on people and light people on
fire it's really dangerous don't ever
put gasoline onto a existing flame it'll
light your hand on fire if you
accidentally pour gasoline on a hidden
ember it can also catch you on fire
diesel fuel or kerosene is a much safer
alternative is nowhere near as volatile
you can't light it with a ferrous rod
and it has trouble even lighting with
matches but kerosene or diesel fuel
burns much hotter burns much longer and
is much safer dip any combustible
material and diesel fuel and it light up
like a champ even the wettest wood will
light on fire with diesel fuel and you
can make a simple hand warmer or heater
using a wick and some diesel fuel and a
tin can
one strange fire tinder is fritos yes
fritos they light on fire surprisingly
well it takes a lighter or a match but
once you get them going they actually
burn quite long and pretty hot it's
great for lighting wet wood on fire
they don't work with ferris rods but
they are edible hey buddy you want some
snacks
however i prefer doritos i think they
light easier they produce a bigger
hotter flame and they taste better
i've never been able to light doritos
with a ferrous rod
another fire starter i like better than
fritos is cheetos because of the shape
they just burn a little bit better
any sort of potato chip especially the
thin ones will burn really well the wavy
ones will also burn but just not quite
as well also thicker potato chips like
the homemade style don't burn as well
and the flavorings don't seem to matter
all that much
the barbecue flavor works just as good
as sour cream and onions
the pringles don't work as well but i
think they're a little bit more
processed one of the reasons why fritos
and potato chips make such good fire
starters is because they're bone dry on
a rainy day when everything's soaking
wet you can pull out a little bag of
fritos pop that open and you've got bone
dry fire starter
one of the best food fire starters are
these little veggie straws because
they're hollow or something they lit
really easy and they burn really well
rice cakes also burn really well
the less coating or flavoring they have
on them the better they work especially
if they don't have any sugar on them
potato sticks also burned really well
though this is a little bit less common
of a food thing popcorn was probably the
best of all the foods i tested
test tested they lit easy and burned hot
these little wafer cookies actually
burned really well and the flame lasted
forever
now i bet a bunch of you are at home
wondering what is the point of lighting
all this food on fire who's going to
bring fritos as a fire starter and the
truth is i don't you have much better
fire starters that you can bring camping
but not everything goes according to
plans sometimes you show up and you've
forgotten your fire starter or you run
out of it and then you're rummaging
through your backpack or through the car
or whatever trying to come up with a
plan b and having all this knowledge can
be really helpful in overcoming and
adapting in those situations top ramen
is a fire starter i've used quite a bit
it doesn't light very easy but once it
starts to burn it burns hot and very
long i've used this when everything is
wet or frozen it's a great way to get
icy wood burning
saltine crackers they work okay they
burn but i actually like the wax paper
wrapper much better as a fire starter
fruit by the foot the wax paper is
actually a fabulous fire starter it's
just paper and paraffin burns like an
absolute champion any food with a wax
paper wrapper is going to be a great
fire starter all right next we're going
to burn a cup of noodles
let them go nathan they're gone they're
gone
now tea bags are kind of a funny fire
starter the bag itself will burn a
little bit and the outside of the
wrapper will burn which is often the
case with tinfoil wrappers but if you
dip an old tea bag in any sort of
flammable petroleum product it actually
makes a really good wick
most cereals are flammable but the more
sugar they have on the outside the less
flammable they are but these little
packages are actually quite flammable
styrofoam burns really well and if you
have a cereal with no added sugar it'll
actually burn half decent coffee filters
work really well as a fire starter you
can use a ferrous rod to light a coffee
filter on fire works pretty well
duct tape actually burns pretty well if
you tear it up into little shreds it
makes a decent fire starter i've in the
past been able to start it using a
ferrous rod but you have to shred it
extremely fine and it's really really
really difficult fishing line also works
well but you have to melt it down much
like you do pine tar before it lights on
fire
next we're gonna try burning
marshmallows
okay really quick we're gonna go through
all the things that i tested that didn't
work marshmallows surprise surprise
don't light on fire stale bread no bueno
tortillas they actually worked okay not
great but okay rice krispie treats kinda
moon pies taste good but are terrible
fire starter kool-aid doesn't work
chapstick doesn't work at all but the
plastic does
liquid nails somebody told me this works
totally doesn't you can make fire with
glycerin and other chemicals mixed
together but it doesn't burn on its own
coffee mate burns at high temperatures
but it's a lousy fire starter nilla
wafer cookies were a dud pork rinds were
forgettable graham crackers were
complete failure wheat fins were meh
cheez-its were a bit of a dud
so were the goldfish crackers
animal crackers didn't work
slim jims didn't work but the wrapper
was actually quite flammable crayons i
melted it and melted it and only the
paper wrapper burned
well guys that's it that's all i got to
show you and i've absolutely trashed my
driveway doing it
but anyways if you like that sort of
video definitely check out our other
videos with all sorts of survival tips
and tutorials including how to build a
fire without matches like a whole bunch
of different ways we got a bunch of knot
tying videos and we've got survival
fishing videos i'll put links in the
video description to all those different
videos thanks for watching guys and
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new adventure videos every saturday
morning if you like this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click subscribe so you can see
other great videos every saturday
morning and hit that bell button and
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]